ich würde auch nicht jünger da können
sie noch so viel fotografieren
die friseurbesuche fehlen mir auch meine
damen und herren dann beginnen wir mit
dem pressebriefing heute am 14 april im
robert-koch-institut dienstag nach
ostern wieder mit professor lothar
wieler präsident des robert
koch-instituts zunächst wie üblich mit
dem statement und danach sind die fragen
der registrierten journalisten möglich
guten morgen meine damen und herren die
kurve 19 zahlen in unserem land zeigen
einige positive tendenzen dazu haben
maßgeblich die bürgerinnen und bürger
unseres landes das heißt also wir alle
beigetragen und dafür danke ich allen
sehr herzlich
schön ist dass unsere anstrengungen
erfolge zeigen also lassen wir uns auch
bitte dafür belohnen lassen sie uns
nicht nachlassen beim einhalten der
regeln nach wie vor wer kann der möge zu
hause bleiben und wer sein zuhause
verlässt der möge abstand halten das ist
eine wichtige forderung die uns bislang
geholfen hat und das wird auch weiter so
sein und halten sie bitte alle halten
wir bitte alle die hygieneregeln 1
das wird auch in der zukunft wichtig
seien um die ausbreitung der kurve 19
pandemie abzusprechen bzw zu
verlangsamen
tatsächlich ein bisschen weiter die
entwicklung abwarten das bild das wir
derzeit sehen ist sehr differenziert
wir haben eines unserer ziele bereits
erreicht
ein wichtiges ziel wir haben die grippe
welle von der kogit 19 welle entkoppelt
sie erinnert sich dass wir das früher
benannt haben das ist nämlich deshalb
wichtig weil dadurch viele betten und
zwei intensivbetten in den
krankenhäusern zur verfügung stehen
auch deuten unsere daten darauf hin dass
die fallzahlen schon über eine längere
zeit nicht mehr so stark ansteigen
das heißt die getroffenen maßnahmen
wirken und das sind gute nachrichten und
ich möchte noch mal sagen das haben wir
allen bürgern und bürgerinnen zu
verdanken
die diese maßnahme neben durchgehalten
haben aber die zahlen haben sich auf
einem relativ hohen niveau eingependelt
es gibt im moment noch keinen
eindeutigen hinweis darauf dass die
zahlen auch weiterhin zurückgehen
und wir sehen nach wie vor starke
regionale unterschiede beim anstieg oder
beim verlangsamen der fallzahlen daher
noch mal lassen sie uns alle uns dafür
belohnen und lassen sie uns die
gemeinsam die getroffenen maßnahmen die
verhaltensmaßnahmen aufrechterhalten
denn die disziplin die wir in den
letzten wochen gehalten haben
die sollten wir weiter halten umso
schöner wird die belohnung sein
unabhängig davon würde doch weiter von
ganz zentraler wichtigkeit seien fälle
schnell zu identifizieren und
kontaktpersonen schnell zu
identifizieren damit für ausbrüche
rasche kennen und auch eindämmen können
daher werden wir auch weiterhin in
deutschland anstrengend unternehmen die
test kapazitäten zu erhöhen denn das ist
ein schlüssel dafür früh infizierte zu
erkennen dass alles benötigen wir nach
wie vor um ein genaueres bild von der
lage zu bekommen das ist wichtig um
gezielt intervenieren zu können und das
ist ja unsere aufgabe ich habe auch ein
weiteres etappenziel erreicht aktuell
sind ausreichende behandlungskapazitäten
in unseren krankenhäusern vorhanden und
zwar insbesondere ausreichende
intensivbetten und beatmungsgeräte
dynamik werden keine engpässe
prognostiziert das kann regional aber
auch sehr unterschiedlich sein das
möchte ich noch mal betonen aber
voraussetzung dafür ist natürlich dass
die anzahl an neuen erkrankungsfällen
nicht wieder ansteigt
lassen sie mich nun zu den einzelnen
zahlen kommen ihnen darstellen wie die
situation in kuwait 19 pandemie in der
welt ist und natürlich insbesondere in
unserem land ich möchte zunächst sehr
deutlich sagen dass wir im vergleich zu
vielen anderen ländern sehr gut dastehen
und es gibt viele kolleginnen und
kollegen aus der welt die uns immer
wieder anrufen und fragen worauf das
beruht sie wissen das weil ich ihnen
diese information den zuletzt zweimal
die woche darstelle
was wir für ein dämmungsmaßnahmen fahren
weltweit sind inzwischen fast zwei
millionen fälle gemeldet worden
und nahezu alle länder sind betroffen
momentan ist das ausbruchsgeschehen
besonders aktiv nach diesen meldezahlen
in nordamerika und auch in europa ich
nenne nur drei staaten um ihnen das
ausmaß noch mal deutlich zu machen in
den vereinigten staaten hatten wir zum
gestrigen zeitpunkt 558.000 fälle
offiziell gemeldet und darunter waren
22.000 100 todesfälle gemeldet
spanien nicht weit von uns sind bislang
166.000 fälle gemeldet dort laufen sich
die todeszahlen auf 17.000 oder italien
wo bislang rund 157 1000 fälle offiziell
gemeldet wurden hier sind 19.900
todesfälle gemeldet worden
eine stetige zunahme die wir jeden tag
nachvollziehen können die auf den
websites des europäischen zentralbank
heitz kontrolle und bei der whu
nachzulesen sind
nur wie sieht die epidemiologische
situation in deutschland aus in
deutschland und das ist der status
vierzehnter 40 uhr wurden offiziell
gemeldet über die gesundheitsämter an
das robert-koch-institut 125.000 98
kurve 19 5 das sind 2000 mehr als am
vortag
und darunter waren offiziell gemeldet
todesfälle das sind 170 mehr als am
vortag
wir schätzen die zahl der genesenen
momentan auf 68.000 100 das heißt also
mehr als die hälfte der offiziell
gemeldeten fälle sind schon wieder
genesen
über ostern das möchte ich aber auch
deutlich sagen wurden weniger fälle
übermittelt und das ist wahrscheinlich
auch darauf zurückzuführen dass
natürlich über die osterfeiertage
weniger fälle von ärzten diagnostiziert
wurden
getestet wurden und auch diese fälle
verzögert übermittelt wurden deshalb
müssen wir diese zahlen immer mit einer
gewissen vorsicht interpretiert
das ist nach unserer ansicht auch der
grund warum die fallzahlen in den
letzten tagen niedriger sind
wir können daher noch nicht abschließend
beurteilen ob die fallzahlen jetzt
tatsächlich sinken in der vergangenen
woche daran möchte ich sie noch mal
erinnern lagen die fallzahlen ja fast
jeden tag zwischen 4000 und 5000 neun
fällen die reproduktions zahl die für
uns eine wichtige marke ist schätzen wir
momentan auf 1,2 sie liegt also nach
unseren berechnungen nicht unter 1 meine
damen und herren
sie wissen dass die fallzahlen und die
zahl der chinesen täglich aktualisiert
werden
sie alle können diese daten sehr
detailliert auf unserem dashboard
einsehen unter krone.at punkt.de und sie
wissen auch dass wir täglich einen neuen
situationsbericht publizieren auch den
finden sie auf unseren websites
dieser neue situationsbericht wird immer
gegen nachmittag am frühen nachmittag
herausgegeben
schauen wir uns ein wenig näher die
betroffenen fälle in deutschland an und
zwar anhand der meldezahlen und daten
die uns zur verfügung stehen die
betroffenen personen sind und
durchschnitt 49 jahre alt bei rund drei
viertel der übermittelten fälle liegen
klinische informationen vor dass heißt
hier haben die gesundheitsämter
klinische informationen genannt bekommen
husten fieber schnupfen und geschmacks
und geruchs verlust wird ebenfalls
häufig berichtet aber erst ab dieser
woche werden wir das systematisch in den
meldedaten erfassen können für etwa zwei
prozent der übermittelten fälle
das ist etwa 2300 menschen ist bekannt
dass sie eine lungenentzündung
entwickelt haben und für 16 prozent der
übermittelten fälle wurde auch eine
hospitalisierung übermittelt das heißt
also dass sie im krankenhaus aufgenommen
wurden das entspricht rund 15.000 fällen
von insgesamt 96.000 fällen wo wir
genügend angaben dazu von den
gesundheitsämtern erhalten haben die
todesfälle in deutschland ich sagte 2009
169 personen die nach den meldungen im
zusammenhang mit kurven 19 verstorben
sind
der anteil der verstorbenen unter den
offiziell gemeldeten fallen sind nun 2,4
prozent sie haben vielleicht bemerkt
dass die zahl der todesfälle und der
anteil der verstorbene unter den
offiziellen meldezahlen in den letzten
tagen kontinuierlich gestiegen ist das
liegt zum einen daran dass wir immer
mehr ausbrüche in alters und
pflegeheimen feststellen müssen auch in
krankenhäusern und hier sieht natürlich
die risikogruppen besonders betroffen
zum anderen sehen wir aber auch generell
immer mehr erkrankungsfälle bei älteren
menschen und die todesfälle die jetzt
offiziell gemeldet werden sind ja solche
todesfälle die betreffen menschen die
vor ein oder zwei wochen erkrankt sind
und dass ich immer noch viele cupid 19
fälle in stationärer behandlung befinden
müssen sie auch hier leider damit
rechnen dass es noch weitere todesfälle
geben wird
und herren wir wollen die aktuellen
infektionsgeschehen möglichst präzise
verstehen und einschätzen und die
entwicklung dadurch so gut wie möglich
analysieren und ich möchte heute einmal
die gelegenheit nutzen um ihn etwas
genauer zu erklären wie wir im
robert-koch-institut zu unseren
einschätzungen kommen wie wir arbeiten
das kann ich ihnen nicht im detail
erklären aber in mir ist wichtig dass
sie verstehen dass wir verschiedene
quellen und informationen für unsere
einschätzung nutzen eben nicht nur die
meldezahlen die ich ihnen eben gerade
vorgelesen habe sondern wir nutzen
darüber hinaus auch viele weitere daten
um das bild zu vervollständigen
um möglichst viele details zu kennen die
unsere lage einschätzung verbessern
ich gebe ihnen heute einen kurzen
überblick dazu da sind zum einen die
meldedaten die gemäß
infektionsschutzgesetz erhoben werden
und diese meldedaten sind eine sehr
wichtige datenquelle für uns wir
erhalten bundesweit informationen zu den
fällen und den todesfällen
das ist wichtig um trends zu erfassen
und für informationen zu regionalen und
auch demografischen verteilen wir können
auch aus den meldezahlen den
erkrankungsbeginn auch die krankheits
schwere und auch mögliche risikofaktoren
ableiten und auf der basis von
meldezahlen erstellen auch unsere
mathematiker verschiedene modellierungen
zum beispiel zur aktuellen entwicklung
der sogenannten out casting
darauf gehe später noch einmal kurz ein
modelliert wird auch die entwicklung der
kommenden tage
also zusammengefasst die modellierung
natürlich auch immer mit unsicherheiten
behaftet aber sie sind ein wichtiger
bestandteil für unsere einschätzung
neben modellierungen ist ein wichtiger
faktor den wir einbeziehen die zahl der
durchgeführten tests und zwar sind
hiervon interesse nicht nur die zahl der
positiven tests sondern natürlich auch
die zahlen
negativen das wird in deutschland aber
nicht zentral erfasst
es gibt nämlich bislang keine
meldepflicht für negative testergebnisse
aber ich denke sie verstehen alle dass
diese zahl sehr wichtig ist um zu
erkennen ob zum beispiel ein anstieg der
fallzahlen darauf zurückzuführen ist
dass einfach vermehrt getestet wird oder
ob es tatsächlich mehr fälle aufgetreten
sind und deshalb für das
robert-koch-institut auf freiwilliger
basis verschiedene datenquellen zusammen
um diese zahl zu erheben
ich nenne hier nur eins das heißt
antibiotikaresistenz evans mag ihn auf
den ersten blick nicht viel mit 19
zusammen zu hängen aber fakt ist dass
dort labore alle diagnosen melden und
die rauskriegen wir einen schönen
einblick darüber wie viele patienten
getestet wurden gegen kuwait 19 und hier
können wir auch sehen wie viele davon
negativ getestet worden
das ist allerdings keine vollständige
erfassung der test in deutschland
weitere tests die wir nutzen und zwar
für andere krankheiten die wir jetzt für
kurve 19 test nach 519 nachweise nutzen
können weil wir sie schon seit vielen
jahren etabliert haben und ihre
aussagekraft sehr gut einschätzen können
diese tests haben wir bislang genutzt
die systeme zur einschätzung der
influenza also der grippe hier können
wir sehen wie verbreitet saß kopf zwar
in der bevölkerung ist wir können sehen
wie viele menschen mit einer
atemwegserkrankung eine praxis besucht
haben oder auch wie viele schwere
verläufe es bei atemwegsinfektionen gibt
und wie viele von diesen schweren
verläufen auf intensivstation behandelt
werden müssen
an diesem system beteiligen sich schon
seit jahren viele arztpraxen und auch
kliniken und die zusammenfassung all
dieser daten hilft uns sehr schön
die information über cupid 19 zu sammeln
und die situation bundesweit besser
einschätzen zu können
das sind verschiedene systeme die die
meldezahlen sinnvoll ergänzen und die
quasi ein ganzes portfolio an
informationen bieten dass unsere
aussagekraft erhöht daneben gibt es noch
zwei weitere bereiche in denen wir daten
erheben und informationen gewinn für
unsere einschätzung zum einen führen wir
natürlich selber auch studien durch das
eine ist die tatsache dass wir bei aus
bous untersuchungen unterstützen
hier werden wir von lokalen behörden
eingeladen und auch bei diesen ausschuss
untersuchung gewinnen wir natürlich
immer zusammen mit den lokalen behörden
wichtige erkenntnisse wir sind auch in
studien beteiligt zu krankheitsverläufen
die von anderen durchgeführt werden die
wir teilweise koordinieren wo wir
teilweise ein partner sind und das hat
sich letzten donnerstag vorgestellt wir
werden bald verschiedene antikörper
studien durchführen um besser
einschätzen zu können wie für menschen
mit 19 bereits durchgemacht haben in
deutschland unter anderem wird es dass
die möglichkeit geben die so genannte
dunkelziffer besser kennenzulernen
ja und der letzte aspekt den ich noch
melden möchte ist der dass auch bürger
uns mit ihren daten helfen
viele von ihnen wissen das aber ich
möchte es noch mal in erinnerung rufen
wir haben ja das sogenannte grippe web
ein sogenanntes citizen science projekt
das haben wir schon viele jahre am start
hier können bürger einmal pro woche
angeben ob sie eine akute
atemwegserkrankungen haben und an
welchen symptomen sie leiden
seit kurzem kann ein teil von ihnen auch
rachenabstriche einschicken die
ebenfalls auf saas kopf zwei untersucht
werden
und das haben wir letzte woche gelaunt
die bürger können und sie inzwischen
auch mit der korona daten spender app
unterstützen
mit dieser app können wir quitt 19
symptome erfassen und diese daten sind
ebenfalls welche die ganz gezielt unsere
anderen informations systeme ergänzen
ich kann dazu sagen diese app wurde seit
der woche bereits schon 300.000 mal
runtergeladen
das ist wirklich ein unglaublicher
erfolg und dafür möchte ich mich
herzlich bedanken
das ist wirklich großartig wie sie uns
unterstützen und wir werden diese
informationen sehr sinnvoll auswerten
lassen nämlich sagen dass wir einen
großen teil von informationen gewinnen
die wir alle zusammen fügen müssen was
nicht trivial ist was viel konzentration
und arbeit bedeutet aber das ist unsere
aufgabe und wir nehmen sie mit sehr viel
verantwortung wahr
unabhängig davon arbeiten wir natürlich
mit vielen partner zusammen
wissenschaftlichen partnern sowohl in
deutschland als auch außerhalb
deutschlands
und wir möchten auch nur drei dinge
nennen die uns zur zeit helfen ein
unheimlich wichtiger und toller erfolg
ist die einrichtung des dw intensiv
registers in dem die freien
intensivbetten bis auf kreisebene
erfasst werden und auch die anzahl
anlaufen und abgeschlossen cupid 19
behandlungen erfasst wenn dieses system
ist wirklich weltweit einmalig und es
gibt viele länder die von uns lernen
möchten
es gibt ein weiteres projekt in dem
bewegungs ströme in deutschland auf der
basis von mobilfunkdaten erfasst wird
aggregierte anonymisierte daten wo wir
sehr schön sehen können wie das
mobilitäts profil da ist und möchte auch
noch mal sagen wir sehen in den letzten
tagen dass die mobilität zunimmt unter
der bevölkerung das ist nicht schlecht
so lange sie die abstandsregel einhalten
das ist der entscheidende punkt wenn sie
rausgehen bitte halten sie die
abstandsregeln 1
denn dann sorgen sie mit dafür dass die
infektion nicht übertragen wird und als
letztes möchte ich noch nennen die
studie cosmo die von der universität
erfurt von frau professor durchgeführt
wird das ist der so genannte cupid 19
snapshot in dem es um die lage unter der
bevölkerung geht also die psychologische
lage der bevölkerung nämlich unter
anderem können wir einschätzen wie gut
die maßnahmen von unseren mitbürgerinnen
und mitbürgern
akzeptierte sie sehen wir tun eine menge
um einschätzen zu können wie die kogit
19 lage in unserem haus in unserem land
ist und ich habe mir nur einen groben
überblick darüber gegeben es gibt viele
verschiedene baustellen bausteine in
diesen daten gefüge und die werden von
uns allen berücksichtigt und natürlich
arbeiten wir an all diesen bausteinen
weiter wir verbessern sie kontinuierlich
und darum sind wir auch auf hinweise
konstruktiv kritische hinweise aus der
bevölkerung als auch natürlich von
kolleginnen und kollegen aus dem inland
als auch aus dem ausland angewiesen
und ich gehe davon aus dass wir noch um
weitere bausteine dazu führen können
darum möchte ich an dieser stelle und
abschließend noch einmal all jenen
danken die dafür sorgen dass für alle
diese informationen erhalten es sind
sehr viele menschen in unserem land sehr
viele hilfreiche geister viele von ihnen
im momentan sehr sehr aufopferungsvoll
ihren job tun die menschen und kollege
in den gesundheitsämtern die ersten
ärzte in den kliniken in den
niedergelassenen praxen und natürlich
viele kolleginnen und kollegen
wissenschaftlichen einrichtungen und
nicht zuletzt meine damen und herren
sind die bürgerinnen und bürger unseres
landes denn die sorgen dafür dass die
regeln eingehalten werden und sie sind
maßgeblich dafür verantwortlich dass die
zahlen in unserem land in den letzten
wochen sich verringert haben und darum
mein ausdrücklicher dank an sie alle
bleiben sie bei der sache
nehmen sie die krankheit ernst belohnen
sie sich dafür in dem sie die regeln
weiter einhalten sie alle
wir alle haben es in der hand mit den
ausgang dieser pandemie zu beeinflussen
zu einem positiven herzlichen dank
vielen dank herr wieder dann kommen wir
jetzt zu den fragen nur kurz die
organisatorische hinweise dass sie eine
frage stellen können indem sie sich
vorher angemeldet haben und rechts unten
das symbol mit dem händchen mit der hand
anklicken
bitte denken sie auch daran wenn ihre
frage beantwortet ist wieder auf das
symbol mit der hand zu klicken
sonst wird die liste immer länger und
genau dann beginnen wir jetzt auf
[Applaus]
jordaans von der agentur ap nationales
und kein nationales kollegen sich am
grab von einer zusammenarbeit mit
partnern außerhalb deutschlands
gesprochen man auch der außenminister
hat heute die usa angeblich wenn sie
etwas ausgeben was für instrumente und
koordinierungs maßnahmen auf
europäischer ebene darüber hinaus
unterwegs sind um diese animieren
ja es sind eine menge von maßnahmen also
zum einen ist es natürlich von wirklich
großer wichtigkeit dass man sich
gegenseitig informiert darüber welche
maßnahmen man denn durchführt und wie
wirksam diese maßnahmen sind wir lernen
und ständig voneinander diese krankheit
ist neu ich sage es immer wieder
wir kennen er seit 17 januar den erreger
eine pandemie die wir in der neuzeit so
noch nicht erlebt haben das heißt sie
lernen von konzepten
wir tauschen zum beispiel konzepte aus
welche test strategien hat man wie
schützt man zb die bestandene wohlrabe
gruppen wie gehen wir damit um dass wir
abstandsregeln einhalten
der zweite aspekt der natürlich sehr
wichtiges sind die aspekte im
wissenschaftlichen bereich wenn es darum
geht gemeinsame anstrengungen zu
unternehmen einen impfstoff zu
entwickeln
hier gibt es ja zum 1 diese
transnationale einrichtungen die auch
über die eu hinaus natürlich wird
und dort wird man sich auf die
bestimmten impfstoffkandidaten einigen
es geht um finanzierung von
forschungsprojekten
auch hier macht es natürlich sinn wenn
einzelne länder gezielt bestimmte
aktivitäten unterstützen und man nicht
zu viel geld in nur einzelne aktivitäten
setzt und ich denke ein wichtiger aspekt
ist natürlich auch der umgang
miteinander wenn es zum beispiel darum
geht dass man patienten aus manchen
ländern übernimmt sie wissen vielleicht
dass deutschland einige patienten aus
anderen ländern auch in deutschland
behandelt es geht um vertrauensbildende
maßnahmen es geht um die lernkurve ich
selber hatte über ostern mehrere
telefonate unter anderem mit dem
bürgermeister aus kiew vitali klitschko
oder auch mit menschen aus downing
street an
wir tauschen uns kontinuierlich aus und
das tun natürlich nicht nur das
robert-koch-institut sondern sondern
viele viele wissenschaftler und
politiker und entscheidend ist dass er
diese informationen austauschen und
voneinander lernen
vielen dank herr eppert von der welt
nachrichtensender neubert
hallo europa können sie uns
kommt jetzt das zdf mittagsmagazin herr
jacobs jacobs
morgen also ja hatte wenn sie ja selber
ausführen dass die melden sich die
offiziellen nicht ausreichen und was
alles einen tieflader einschätzung ich
waren wir stehen dann die gemeinden
prominent im zentrum ihrer darstellung
ist und was ich werden noch wissen
möchte österreichischen
wissenschaftsminister hat jetzt am
freitag eine erste landesweite studie
porsche dann drüber denn studien an
stichproben sich nicht ganz geklappt
signalwege wochen ein bild zu machen
weil es möglichen infektionsgeschehen
seitenraum und das dann auch nicht
obwohl das nicht möglich in deutschland
er hatte zur ersten frage diese zahlen
sind eben die offiziellen meldezahlen
und sie sind natürlich wichtig für ein
verständnis der trends also wenn sie
auch nicht einen einfluss einen einblick
geben da rein
die welt wie hoch die dunkelziffern sind
so sind sie doch die zahlen die man
natürlich international vergleicht den
meldezahlen es gibt der internationale
meldewege es gibt regeln
es gibt regeln von der whu und es gibt
regeln vom europäischen center for
disease control
es gibt eine infektionsschutzgesetz und
natürlich sind das zahlen die wirklich
im mittelpunkt einer berichterstattung
stehen müssen will die vergleichbarkeit
darstellen neben diesen zahlen
publizieren wir eine reihe von studien
alle diese studien im epidemiologischen
bulletin oder auf unserer website können
ja von menschen von fachleuten als auch
von bürgern eingesehen werden also der
vergleich der offiziellen meldezahlen
ist eine wichtige größe und das wird
auch so bleiben aber nochmal für die
fachleute heißt es eben dass wir auch
die anderen zahlen im kopf haben müssen
das ist der wichtigste punkt den ich
heute machen wollte die studie in
österreich die sie ansprachen
ja wir planen in deutschland auch solche
studien
sie werden auch kommen wir werden
innerhalb der nächsten ein zwei wochen
die serologischen studien beginnen
aber ich möchte noch mal sagen das ist
nicht nur geschuldet der tatsache dass
deutschland natürlich auch ein land ist
das größer ist als österreich sondern es
ist geschuldet der tatsache dass wir
auch relativ früh zu beginn dieser
pandemie sind und es macht auch
epidemiologisch erst sinn zu einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt eine
querschnittsstudie heben
denn sonst haben wir auch eine starke
und erfassung das heißt also diese daten
kommen aber sie brauchen nicht nur eine
zeit um die studie durchzuführen sondern
sie machen eben auch epidemiologisch
erst ab einem bestimmten zeitpunkt sind
wenn wir zu früh
solche studien durchführen dann können
wir den verlauf der pandemie natürlich
schlechter einschätzen wo wir uns
nochmal mit der welt herr ruppert aller
räubert und war ein versuch wert dann
kommt jetzt die taz herr kreutzfeldt
kreutzfeldt
und
dann probieren wir es mit rtl rtl man
sie mich super was sagen sie dazu den
empfehlungen der leopoldina und was
empfiehlt denn das robert-koch-institut
am eisenbahn sollten die gelockert
werden und wie genau könnte das aussehen
ja die empfehlung der leopoldina sind
empfehlungen wir im großen teil der
erwartungshaltung entsprechen
es gab ja schon mehrere papiere die in
den letzten wochen kursierten und ideen
die kursierten klar ist dass man
bestimmte messzahlen haben muss und die
sind ja auch im leopoldina paper nicht
genannt also zb diese berühmte zahl r
die reproduktionsrate hier wollen wir
natürlich das sagen wir auch schon
länger haben wir wirklich das interesse
dass diese r zahl unter 1 geht oder bei
1 ist das ist ein wichtiger faktor
die anzahl der fälle pro tag über einen
zeitraum von mindestens einer woche
sollte auch einen gewissen einen
gewissen wert nicht überschreiten
ansonsten sehen wir in den
einschätzungen des robert-koch-institut
uns denen die von der leopoldina gemacht
werden
mit ausnahme von kleinen details keine
größeren unterschiede
wir haben eine etwas differenzierter
einschätzung zur eröffnung der schon
wir denken das ist biologisch sehr viel
sinn macht erst die älteren in der
schule wieder zu öffnen aber dass das
sind ja nur einschätze nochmal die
entscheidung dazu das möchte ich auch
immer wieder betonen die werden ja von
politikern getroffen aber vor älteren
würden wir zum beispiel denken dass sie
die abstandsregel wahrscheinlich besser
einhalten insofern wäre der biologisch
sinnvoll
aber es gibt gründe für und wider die
nachher ausdiskutiert werden ich will
nochmal eines betonen wir haben nach wie
vor keine blaupause ja diese pandemie
gab es so noch nicht es gibt auch nicht
immer ein falsch und richtig sondern wir
werden vieles auch einfach ausprobieren
müssen
und werden sehen was dann nachher
wirksam ist aber im großen und ganzen
enthält die leopoldina stellungnahme die
maßnahmen die man halt sich überleben
können dann vielen dank und noch mal
vorher vorhin schon kurz gebeten auf das
händchen drücken damit sie dann aus der
liste auf da draußen sind vielen dank
jetzt reuters herr wackelt erwartet
hören sie uns ja den zahlen ein
unternehmen gewesen im verein sind das
auto einfach geschäfts geschrieben daher
unter tage
anschließend nimmt sie sind also die
zahlen schätzen wir ja es gibt keine
meldepflicht dahingehend dass ein
patient diese krankheit überstanden
hatten die zahlen schätzen wir in erster
linie und wie schätzen sie eher
konservativ also diese zahlen davon
können wir ausgehen dass eben wirklich
inzwischen mehr die krankheit an der
kranke wieder genesen sind als als
infiziert wurden da steht aber nicht im
widerspruch also nur spannungsverhältnis
über die ostertage dass das möchte ich
auch deutlich sagen das ist natürlich
mit einberechnet aber die zahlen der sie
sagen dass die zahlen immer zu nehmen
der verstorbene als auch der genesene
das ist korrekt aber wir können noch
nicht von einer eindämmung sprechen wir
haben nach wie vor hohe zahlen pro tag
wir sehen eine verlangsamung ja das ist
das was sie auch dargestellt habe wie
sie in einer verlangsamung
aber es ist noch kein eindeutiger trend
dahingehend wir sind noch immer nicht
mit unseren berechnungen zumindest unter
einem r von 1 also von einer eindämmung
können wir nicht sprechen wir sprechen
von positiven tendenzen und wir müssen
weiter daran arbeiten dass die dann eben
auch weiter positiv bleiben
vielen dank wir probieren es noch ein
letztes mal mit der taz herr kreutzfeldt
der creutzfeldt hören sie uns gut dann
klappt das heute nicht
frau eckert sagen sie doch mal bitte
redaktion dazu ja das ist ein sehr
interessante frage
ich habe gerade auch mit einem kollegen
der dort im krankenhaus arbeitet mit dem
wir auch regelmäßig kontakt haben noch
dazu telefoniert bzw e-mail-austausch
gestanden also das ist noch unklar
was wir dort genau sehen es gibt
verschiedene theorien das eine ist es
könnte sein dass es patienten sind die
zum beispiel falsch negativ
diagnostiziert wurden zunächst eine
hypothese ist die das virus nach einer
gewissen zeit immer noch ausgeschieden
wird aber eher virus genom also nicht
virus das vermehrungsfähige ist das ist
die hypothese die der kollege der der
selber sehr intensiv in diese ausbrüche
bekämpfung als kliniker involviert ist
favorisiert das ist
dies ist nicht plausibel nach der
meinung von der meisten fachleute unter
anderem auch seine eigene meinung dass
es sich um die infektion in dem großen
maße handelt aber ich kann dazu nur
sagen das sind alles bislang hypothesen
all das wird genauer untersucht und wir
werden das irgendwann beantworten können
zurzeit ist das aber einfach noch nicht
möglich weil die krankheit eben neues
wir noch viele fragen haben die wir noch
nicht beantworten können
[Musik]
ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern es
mag sein dass es beobachtet wurde aber
ich persönlich habe davon keine kenntnis
so vielen dank frau satori wdr
produziert das dazu sagen ist letzte
woche wissen wenn es noch wenn ich mal
eine geringe virus lässt bekommt das
dann wahrscheinlich auch der verlauf der
krankheit gesichert kann man das so
sagen nein dieser zusammenhang ist
sicher so ist ist definitiv nicht
gesichert es ist eine hypothese wir
kennen solche zusammenhänge eigentlich
in erster linie von magen darm
infektionen da wissen wir dass es
tatsächlich einen zusammenhang gibt
zwischen der infektions dosis und der
krankheit schwere atemwegserkrankungen
ist das auf jeden fall ungewöhnlich ich
will das nicht ausschließen aber es gibt
bislang keine gesicherten informationen
dazu dass das im falle von kogit 19 der
fall sei
das ist eine hypothese die überprüft
werden muss vielen dank nochmal die
freundliche erinnerung wer seine frage
gestellt hat auf das händchen zu drücken
damit sie in der liste nicht mehr
auftauchen jetzt die berliner zeitung
frau oder herr dankbar wenn sie uns
nein dann kommt jetzt mit watch
feldbusch feldbusch ja wir an ich wollte
fragen wie der gegenschlag sind weise
auch sie informationen zu guttenberg
informationen und asyl daran halten was
ich von falschinformationen halt wo sich
glaube ich nicht nicht sagen
es ist bedauerlich es ist nicht
hilfreich in der ganzen debatte
ich muss ihnen allerdings sagen ja wir
haben diese falschinformation im blick
wir haben aber tatsächlich nicht die
möglichkeiten gezielt gegen diese
falschinformation oder gezielt dagegen
zu argumentieren die die whu und auch
viele andere einrichtungen haben sehr
sehr viele unternehmen sehr sehr viele
anstrengungen um diese falschinformation
ganz gezielt zu entlarven
wir sind in diese arbeiten auch peripher
mit involviert aber tatsächlich besitzen
wir nicht genügend ressourcen um diese
falschinformation auch jedes mal
entgegen etwas entgegenzusetzen
das ist das ist so und das kann ich
ihnen leider nicht anders beantworten
vielen dank frau will man vom
handelsblatt
infektionszahlen dass auch dieser was
noch nicht abschließend sagen kann ob
die fallzahlen tatsächlich sinken wenn
wir jetzt worten oder ähnliches niveau
haben wir heute gilt an dieser aussage
nach wie vor oder wäre das schon ein
zusätzlicher hinweis wenn ja wie stark
sie tatsächlich fallen wenn ich darf
einen weiteren fragen sie haben gesagt
die meldung von testergebnissen kann ist
dass bisher keine pflicht gibt hat sich
das rp dafür stark gemacht dass diese
pflicht gibt warum die ein bisschen
nicht will dass das ministerium also zur
ersten frage nur wenn morgen die zahlen
vielleicht höher oder geringer sind als
heute das würde uns nicht lange um die
einschätzung zu ändern da braucht es
schon noch ein paar mehr daten ja das
robert koch institut macht sich dafür
stark dass wir solche meldepflichten
haben wir möchten natürlich alle
möglichen informationen gemeldet haben
ich habe ja schon gesagt wie schön es
wäre wenn wir elektronische
patientenakten hätten dann hätten wir
sehr sehr viele informationen aber eine
meldepflicht hängt ja von vielen
spielern ab weil das
infektionsschutzgesetz ist ein
zustimmungspflichtiges gesetz bei denen
länder etwas zu sagen haben es gibt eine
reihe gründe warum ein gesetz so oder so
entschieden wird dass es gibt in im
bereich der des robert koch instituts
und auch im bereich des
gesundheitsministeriums niemanden gegen
eine meldepflicht von von negativen
negativen diagnosen ist
gab es nicht nur vielen dank frau
kreisky von bloomberg tv hallo frau
christin das gehört uns nicht
dann schalten wir zu medico direkt hallo
wenn sie uns wir haben ja die kohle
heute frage richtet sich auf den umgang
der esel serien oder wählen dass die gws
in der seit geschäfts werden in kürze in
der breite die möglichkeit bestehen
haben die körperhaltung zu führen für
das man über die mobilisierung aussagen
offenbar frage richtet sich content
darauf gibt es überlegungen sollten
immunisierten die möglichkeit zu geben
sich sichtbar zu halten also etwas geld
immunitätsgesetz mit dem karl
auszustellen was man sichtbar van der
weil es möchte auf den kontaktpersonen
die abwesenheit eines risikos sie habe
ich ja also ich kann mir vorstellen eine
reihe von überlegungen gibt ich möchte
zunächst aber folgendes sagen
tatsächlich gibt es momentan wirklich
niemanden der weiß ob alle menschen die
infiziert wurden auch wirklich immun
sind
und es gibt auch niemanden der sagen
kann wenn sie immun sind wie lange sie
den immun sind es gibt bislang wirklich
nur schätzungen vergleiche zu anderen
ähnlichen krankheiten märz saß es gibt
hinweise von anderen kroner wären es
gibt ja eine reihe von corona werden die
einfach nur leicht erkältungskrankheit
machen und das heißt also wir wissen de
facto noch nicht sehr viel darüber wie
stark die immunität ist bislang gibt es
auch nur wissen zu antikörpern und wir
wissen dass es antikörper gibt die
neutralisieren würden also wirklich in
der zelle gute im labor nachgewiesen
dann das virus auch unschädlich machen
können sozusagen
aber wir haben noch keine information
also da gibt es theater verdünnung
reihen von antiken wie stark das war
also da gibt es eine große und eine
große unsicherheit darüber und das
werden wir auch im laufe der zeit erst
erfahren das ist das eine
und das zweite ist ja die überlegung was
dann mit mit mit immunen menschen
geschieht also wenn sie immun sind dann
wäre es natürlich großartig das zu
wissen und dann wäre es natürlich
naheliegend dass diese personen dann
auch bestimmte tätigkeiten vielleicht
eher ausführen können als andere person
das ist klar
man könnte auch dann mit ihnen eben
infektions epidemiologisch anders
umgehen
da kann man sich eine menge konzepte aus
denkt aber ich möchte noch mal sagen
solange wir über den immunität status
also ob die menschen wirklich vor einer
zweiten infektion geschützt sind so
lange wir darüber so wenig wissen kann
man sich eine menge von konzepten
ausdenken aber die greifen erst dann
wenn wir den immunstatus wirklich kennen
wir müssen nicht zwingend davon ausgehen
dass ein antikörper status mit einem
immunstatus gleichzusetzen
vielen dank wir probieren es mit bayern
reporter markus röder und noch mal die
kleine bitte dass diejenigen die ihre
frage gestellt haben nochmal das
händchen klicken kann man schon machen
also nach unseren kenntnissen gibt es
einzelne patienten die tatsächlich schon
sieben tage nach der infektion
antikörper ausbilden das sind daten die
unter anderem erhoben wurden von der
gruppe der in münchen die ersten
patienten sehr intensiv untersucht haben
also ab sieben tage das ist sehr sehr
früh
ich glaube die mehrheit wird
wahrscheinlich auch als später
normalerweise sagt man nur nach zwei
wochen kann man den wunsch kann man ein
antikörper staates nachweis sehen
zurzeit gibt es sehr viele entwicklungen
auf dem markt der tests
es gibt eine reihe von tests deren
qualität wir aber noch nicht kennen
die werden
unter anderem von der whu im rahmen mit
einer institution die heisst find
untersucht und evaluiert dazu braucht
man wirklich standardisierte
standardisierte serien von patienten die
eben die infektion schon durchgemacht
haben um das vergleich zu können nach
meinem kenntnisstand gibt es zurzeit auf
jeden fall von der firma euroimmun einen
leiser der eine hohe qualität hat
es werden aber sicher in zukunft auch
weitere tests kommen und ich gehe davon
aus dass bald auch das wirklich breit
angeboten werden kann um den immunstatus
zu testen
also den antikörper staates zu testen
wie gesagt wir wissen immer noch nicht
genau wie der mond startet aber es ist
sehr wichtig dass diese test eine hohe
qualität haben
es gibt nichts schlimmeres als test
dienen hoch fall schläge hohen falsch
negative nur falsch positiven wert haben
weil dann die ergebnisse eben eine
geringe aussagekraft hat und auch das
gehört halt immer zu wissenschaftlichen
studien dazu die die aussagekraft eines
testes muss immer berücksichtigt werden
und darum müssen wir gerade jetzt am
anfang wenn wir solche tests machen die
immer noch validieren die ergebnisse
unter anderem durch neutralisation 1
tests in der zellkultur gehe ich von
auch ist dass die blutproben wie normal
jetzt auch beim hausarzt genommen werden
können klar ich würde wahrscheinlich
auch andere modelle geben das ist
regional sehr unterschiedlich die
versorgung in deutschland durch die
kassenärztlichen vereinigung durch die
ambulanten praxen ist sehr
unterschiedlich regional geregelt es
gibt verschiedenste modelle
da sind einige tolle dabei wo dann auch
andere wiederum was von lernen können
das ist auch ein sehr dynamischer
prozess
vielen dank die gts nachrichtenagentur
herr hoffmann ich habe nochmal eine
nachfrage sie haben mehrfach gesagt das
ist eigentlich noch nichts wirklich zu
sagen dass man sich die zahlen jetzt
stabilisiert haben dass man das auch
morgen nicht sagen können wird so ein
produkt und länder ihre antworten über
lockerungen beraten haben bis jetzt
richtig verstanden dass das morgen
eigentlich über verschoben werden muss
sprechen sie mit der kanzlerin
welchen rat geben sie ihr ganz konkret
für morgen also wie die informationen
die wir haben die stellen wir zur
verfügung das ist ganz klar
das heißt also wir zeigen das
epidemiologische geschehen wir bewerten
das und wie wir
wir geben unser wissen weiter nach
bestem wissen und gewissen und dass die
entscheidung wie gesagt liegt eben nicht
bei uns es gibt ja auch eine menge
andere personen und menschen und
fachleute die ihren rat geben und ihre
information weiter tragen was morgen
entschieden wird das kann ich ihnen
nicht sagen
vielen dank interview könnt ihr mich
nicht wenn sie uns jetzt
aber nicht nochmals vor dem zitierten
nur stand heute geht es da ist schon
eine einschätzung von gehrke jede zweite
frage zur leopoldina wir empfehlen jetzt
sozusagen man spielt für den
öffentlichen personennahverkehr
angenommen diese vorschläge würden jetzt
so umgesetzt wie hoch schätzen sie das
infektionsrisiko jetzt zum beispiel in
der folgenden bahn oder s bahn ein
wenn dort jeder eine normale vielleicht
nicht medizinische am sagen wir ja
stoffmaske trägt ist dann dort das
risiko sich zu infizieren
pikant niedriger also ich kann ihnen
noch nichts sagen zu dunkelziffer es
gibt wirklich noch keine repräsentativen
daten das tut mir leid dass oft erst
möglich sein wenn wir antikörpertest
haben und zwar eben auch antikörper
tests die wirklich repräsentativ für
deutschland sind es gibt ja verschiedene
regionen wo zum beispiel größere
ausbrüche schon unterwegs sind dort ist
es natürlich so dass die dunkel zieht
dass dort mehr menschen infiziert wurden
und man dann bestimmte zahlen hat aber
die kann man nicht immer übertragen auf
das ganze land
also ich kann dazu leider noch keine
auskunft geben da wir viel getestet
haben in deutschland und das ist auch
einer der gründe
wo und wie viele andere kollegen
kollegen aus dem ausland fragen da wir
viel getestet haben ist bei uns die
dunkelziffer wahrscheinlich nicht so
hoch wie sie vielleicht anderswo zu sein
scheint die frage nach den masken
also es ist sehr wichtig dass in der
öffentlichkeit immer klar verstanden
wird dass wir drei verschiedene arten
von sogenannten masken haben und das
robert koch institut hat die wirksamkeit
von masken immer eingeschätzt anhand der
vorhandenen wissenschaftlichen evidenz
und zurzeit ist der kenntnisstand folgen
es gibt richtige masken die nennen wir
ffp 2 oder ffp drei masken und diese
masken die schützen denjenigen der die
massen trägt in hohem maße vor einer
virus ansteckung will nämlich die
atemluft so gefiltert wird dass viren
quasi kaum durch diese
filter durchkommen das sind also masken
die natürlich in erster linie bei den
ärzten und pflegepersonal und und
erziehung und gesundheitspersonal vor
enthalten sein sollen und solchen die
eben wirklich fälle pflegen
das sind diese richtigen masken dann
gibt es eine zweite art von masken das
ist der mund nasenschutz aber dieser
mutterschutz das sind sonate op masken
und chirurgische masken das sind auch
medizinal produkte die eine bestimmte
qualität haben eine prüfung unterlaufen
sind die also genormt sind von diesen
masken wissen wir
oder von diesem mund nasenschutz wissen
wir dass wenn man selber erkrankt ist
also hustet niest und so weiter dass die
viren gehe über tröpfchen ausgeschieden
werden nicht so weit fliegen das also
der der dritte der gegenüber steht quasi
zu einem bestimmten teil geschützt wird
und zwar signifikant geschützt wird aber
es ist natürlich kein hundertprozentiger
schutz das heißt also diese art von mund
nasenschutz reduziert das risiko dass
ein patient einen anderen patienten an
steckt das ist der grund warum eben
chirurgen zum beispiel bei der operation
solche masken hat ihr mund nasen schutz
tragen damit sie eben ins operationsfeld
keine keime einbringen das dritte
worüber jetzt in den letzten wochen oft
gesprochen wird das nennen wir mal das
nennen manche community mars oder wir
nennen es jetzt mund nasen deckung warum
sagen wir nicht schuld sondern bedeckung
erstens diese selbst gemacht oder
stoffmasken wie immer man diese selbst
gemachten mund nasen bedeckungen die
sind natürlich sehr unterschiedlich in
ihrer qualität die kann man ja gar nicht
einschätzen sind unterschiedliche gewebe
unterschiedlich angefertigt mit einem
unterschiedlichen wirkungsgrad
die werden sicher auch dazu beitragen
dass wenn man hustet und niest also wenn
man erkrankt ist das natürlich die
tröpfchen nicht so weit fliegen
aber sie haben sicher nicht so einen
guten effekt wie die chirurgische mund
nasen schutz und darum können wir sie
sehr sehr schlecht einschätzen was sich
allerdings in den letzten wochen ergeben
hat ist ein aspekt der am anfang dieser
pandemie nicht klar war es gibt
tatsächlich immer wieder berichte
darüber dass menschen bevor sie symptome
haben schon viren ausscheiden 1 bis 3
tage bevor sie symptome haben und wenn
man dann natürlich sollten mund nasen
schutz trägt dann ist die chance dass
man weniger viren ausscheidet größer
davon
nach dem jetzigen kenntnisstand und es
wird auch gerade ein 1 1 cochrane review
publiziert dazu das glaube ich weiß
nicht jetzt in den nächsten tagen oder
nächsten woche erscheint nach dem
jetzigen kenntnisstand gibt es keine
wissenschaftliche evidenz dafür dass das
wirklich signifikant reduziert aber wenn
man diese masken benutzt dann kann es
sein dass man dadurch insgesamt die
ausscheidung also die chance dass andere
angesteckt wird vielleicht dass man die
reduziert aber ich möchte dazu sagen das
ist eine annahme es ist immer noch nicht
bewiesen es gibt keine studien aber
sagen wir mal es ist eine annahme aber
was ganz wichtiges diese annahme trägt
wirklich nur dann wenn sie als ein
sogenanntes add-on gesehen wird also als
ein zusätzlicher kleiner baustein
das schützt nicht groß es hilft nur dann
wenn die abstandsregeln eingehalten
werden
und wenn die hygieneregeln eingehalten
werden also hände waschen in die
armbeuge niesen und husten wenn es als
ein quasi ein zusätzlicher kleiner
baustein ist aber wir dürfen wirklich
nicht den fehler aus meiner sicht machen
dass wir denken durch diese masken wären
wir dann geschützt durch diese mund
nasen bedeckung es ist ein zusätzliches
add on das darf nicht dazu führen dass
man die anderen dinge vernachlässigt und
man muss natürlich auch damit den mund
nasen bedeckung gut umgehen denn
natürlich kann man sich dann auch daran
infizieren wenn man damit nicht
hygienisch sauber umgeht das heißt also
der umgang mit diesem unten außen
bedeckung der muss noch gut vermittelt
werden und auch trainiert wird aus
meiner sicht
vielen dank nrw tv können sie uns
die erfolgreiche behandlung mit calcium
kanal beispiel die thc publiziert gibt
es dazu auch eine tut mir leid
wir haben also noch nach meinem
kenntnisstand gibt es bislang noch keine
wirklich überzeugenden klinischen
studien die in eindeutigen hinweis
darauf geben was man tun kann um die
krankheit dienst krankheit für
signifikante zu verbessern tut mir leid
dazu kann ich ihnen nicht sagen
hallo
dann probieren das nochmal bei denen wo
es vorher nicht geklappt hat frau kriege
von bloomberg tv
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja das ist eine der antworten die die
ich ihnen nicht geben kann das muss
natürlich etwas was wichtig ist ist das
natürlich die staaten sich gut
miteinander absprechen bei den maßen
aber das ist sicher ein wichtiger aspekt
was was was sie tun werden das vermag
ich nicht zu sagen
die glaskugel habe ich leider nicht aber
bezüglich der der frage die sie haben
bezüglich der einträge von anderen
ländern das ist eine extrem gute und
wichtige frage und ist auch gut dass sie
das nochmal ansprechen
wir werden ja auch jetzt wo wir eine
erste welle ganz gut eingedämmt haben
wird dieses virus ja nicht verschwinden
wir haben ja nach wie vor dem
hintergrund dass ein großer teil der
bevölkerung nicht immun ist das heißt es
wir haben eine pandemie das virus wird
sich weiter ausbreiten
darum müssen wir weiter auch bestimmte
maßnahmen fahren wir müssen nach wie vor
diese distanz regeln einhalten und in
der letzten woche wurde auch beschlossen
dass menschen die aus anderen ländern
nach deutschland einreisen zwei wochen
in eine quarantäne zu gehen haben das
ist eine sinnvolle maßnahme
und momentan sehe ich auch keinen grund
diese maßnahme aufzuheben in der
nächsten zeit das ist ein wichtiger
punkt die zwei wochen ergeben sich
daraus dass wir eben eine
inkubationszeit von etwa zwei wochen
haben und wir müssen darauf nach wie vor
ein ganz ganz großen schwerpunkte auf
legen dass alle personen die infiziert
sind und erkannt werden eben rasch in
quarantäne gehen beziehungsweise wenn
die erkrankt sind eben isoliert werden
und behandelt werden damit sich das
krankheitsgeschehen nicht weiter
ausbreitet das wird auch in den nächsten
monaten ein großer kern von allen
anstrengungen sollen in allen ländern
dieser welt
vielen dank wir probieren es nochmal bei
herrn kreutzfeldt von der taz herr
kräuter sozusagen oder jetzt wichtig ist
so interpretiere unsere nation auf der
testergebnisse nach der infizierten sei
nun ist aber da sind ein paar tagen
keine neuen zahlen wird man sich noch
mal sagen ob sie neue zahlen haben wie
sich die zahl der durchgeführten test
entwickelt haben
zuletzt war mir gar nicht mehr stark
gestiegen ist immer noch unser kinder
1000 jetzt in den letzten wochen gegeben
es war ja angekündigt worden
das stark auszuweiten und kapazitäten
sollte ja nach den ankündigungen
geschnappt oder sei nahrung würde ja das
kann ich ihnen nicht im einzelfall
beantworten wenn natürlich das wär
getestet wird das entscheiden die
lokalen gesundheitsämter als auch die
ärzte
wir werden wir haben bestimmte tests
schemata auf unseren webseiten
entwickelt nachdem sich der zehn richten
und die lokalen gesundheitsbehörden die
die wir wissen tatsächlich das in den
letzten woche die test kapazität größer
war als die anzahl der durchgeführten
tests den grund dafür kann ich ihnen
momentan nicht nennen
wir werden aber zukünftig auch mehr
tests durchführen wir entwickeln zum
beispiel strategien wie wir test
durchführen zum beispiel in altenheimen
oder ein pflegeheim wo wir dann auch
zukünftig immer mehr dafür sorge tragen
müssen dass man das personal dass er die
menschen dort behandelt vielleicht
häufiger testet es werden immer mehr
strategien entwickelt die wir jetzt
anlaufen lassen können und dazu brauchen
eine höhere test kapazität und wir sehen
ja auch leider das zum einen ist es ja
eine positive entwicklung dass wir
insgesamt weniger zahlen haben das
natürlich auch eine erklärung dafür sein
könnte dass eben weniger menschen
getestet werden aber wir sehen auf der
anderen seite auch inzwischen ja
vermehrt ausbrüche in krankenhäusern
pflegeheim in altenheim so dass ich auch
davon ausgeht dass die anzahl der tests
wieder erhöht wird
und klar ist wenn eben bestimmte
maßnahmen gelockert werden sollten
dann müssen wir auch bestimmte dinge
anders testmuster andere test regime
wieder anfahren um so früh wie möglich
beginnen de ausbrüche zu erkennen also
ich es kann es mag sein ja aber ich
glaube dass moment also nach der in der
letzten woche die information da war es
glaube ich weniger chemikalien es kann
sein dass abstrich material teilweise
fehlte aber sie haben recht das kann ein
grund dafür seien aber das ausmaß dessen
vermag ich nicht einzuschätzen
vielleicht doch von mir noch der
kommentar die tests zahlen werden ja
immer mittwochs im situationsbericht
veröffentlicht also wir bitten auch ein
bisschen geduld jetzt probieren wir es
noch mal mit dem reporter rainer
kurlemann
vielleicht klappt es daher jetzt auch
noch werden sie da war dieser linie
festhalten wenn ja warum wieder
anregungen dass man jüngere patienten
verstorben
die gesunde ältere ja schön dass ihr das
nochmal fragen dann kann ich das zum
dritten mal nun klarstellen es gibt vom
robert-koch-institut keine empfehlung
keine option durchzuführen ja also das
ist schlichtweg nicht korrekt wir haben
verschiedene dokumente erstellt und ein
dokument das wir erstellt haben ist ein
missverständlicher satz drin gewesen auf
den wurden sie aufmerksam gemacht ich
weiß nicht mehr von einer gesellschaft
einer fachgesellschaft von pathologen
diesen satz haben wir entsprechend
korrigiert wir haben niemals sage ich
noch mal ausdrücklich habe ich das auch
langsam ein bisschen nervt das immer
wieder erzählt wird dass wir obduktion
nicht wünschen wir haben niemals darum
gebeten keine obduktion durchzuführen im
gegenteil habe ich mehrfach in
pressemitteilung auch gesagt wie wichtig
es ist obduktion durch sind genau aus
dem grund den sie nennen
gerade wenn es um jüngere menschen geht
oder um gesunde menschen ohne
vorerkrankungen ist natürlich ist sehr
sehr wichtig dass wir verstehen warum
diese menschen verstorben sind
das gibt nicht nur hinweise darauf über
das krankheitsgeschehen das ist ein
wichtiger aspekt sondern es gibt eben
auch hinweise darauf wie man eine
therapie gestalten kann das ein ganz
ganz wichtiger punkt und wie gesagt hier
lernen ja wirklich täglich dazu und ich
denke und wir lernen wirklich immer noch
nach wie vor dazu und gerade wenn es um
die behandlung von patienten geht ist
das natürlich sehr wichtig unabhängig
davon möchte ich aber auch noch einmal
klarstellen ich selber habe auch drei
jahre in abteilung für pathologie in ulm
gearbeitet ich war dort nicht
schwerpunktmäßig mit obduktion betraut
aber es gelingt nicht immer den
pathologen nicht eindeutig festzustellen
warum warum woran eine person verstorben
ist das ist nicht immer so trivial
das heißt also auch dort gibt es
genügend wissenschaftliche literatur
klar zeigt dass man nicht immer die
todesursache eindeutig erkennen kann
aber obduktion sind wichtig sie geben
uns hinweise und darum brauchen wir
diese da
eine nachfrage dazu haben sie denn die
erkenntnisse wie selbstverständlich das
ist dass diese entsprechende
interessanten das tut mir leid das weiß
ich nicht das weiß nicht so haben wir
noch etwa ein halbes dutzend namen in
der liste die haben aber alle schon
fragen gestellt ich bitte um verständnis
dass wir das nicht noch mal dran nehmen
können und eine frage von radio münchen
herr oder frau schmidt die haben wir
glaube ich noch nicht chef härter frau
schmidt nee dann war das doch schon
erledigt dann bedanken uns ganz herzlich
doch über eine stunde gedauert und wir
sehen uns oder hören uns freitag wieder
vielen dank